first of all I have a specific question
for Oscar cuz I'd love to know what it's
like to throw Sir Ben Kingsley into a
ditch it's really fun it's very
invigorating it was a mixture of Sir Ben
Kingsley and his stunt double so we you
know for the really heavy stuff
yeah but overall operation finale it's
such a such a heavy important story hmm
and I'm wondering if there's ever a
moment during filming before filming
after filming word that it's sort of a
specific moment where I really hate you
the the weight of it the history of it
anything like that well every once in a
while you would meet an extra who's
parents and had and survived the
Holocaust or who had lost family members
in the Holocaust because Argentina has a
pretty big Jewish immigrant population
and you also realize that Argentina went
through its own military dictatorship of
late 1970s early 80s and they had
concentration camps and they had mass
killings and so walking around the
streets of Buenos Aires this beautiful
city beautiful democratic nation are the
sufferers and perpetrators of this kind
of violence do you realize how possible
this is I was speaking with Ben and he
said that that there wasn't a lot of
conversations really on set about what
kind of dynamic you had wanted to have
with Peter had seen two scene and moment
to moment I'd love for you to like
expand on that a little bit because it's
so interesting to me that you sort of
just felt your way around the
conversations and you felt your way
around each other and sort of what you
wanted their dynamic to be in that
moment well it was to me I mean Chris I
had tons and tons of conversations but
but really that's the dynamic of of
Eichmann he's a mystery and he's just
this mysterious force of gravity of
nature and so the fact that that that is
how Serban approached the role
it was perfect because it really
actually created a dynamic of how do we
get in there how do you and Ian talk and
how do you you know and the truth is the
we had gone out to eat before we started
servin and I and we had like a long
conversation where we just talked you
know in a in a vague way about not
specifically about this scene and what
was gonna be said here but he from the
first table read and he was already
off-book he knew you know you know I you
said his lines and everyone else's lines
so he was just he was ready to go he was
primed and ready to go so there wasn't
there was a much need to talk about it
was just about doing it and then once we
were doing it Chris would come in and
adjust something or you know kind of
shape it so it would kind of you know
reach a certain place that was it was
thrilling to work with him when you're
when you're playing a character that
where there's a there's a template
there's a real person there's this
pictures you can see and ready you can
see how do you avoid falling into the
trap of just being a copy how do you how
do you put your own take into a
character when it's a real person well
it's impossible to copy because I'm you
know I'm not no and it's really just a
snapshot of what about this person
what kind of hits me and then trying to
focus on that so you never really I mean
spent at least the way that I work I am
you know I'm not a mimic I don't I don't
have that skill so I've - something
different and so just focusing on the
circumstances and what he's feeling and
what he's trying to do and hopefully
taking some of you know listening to his
recordings and reading his book
meditating on that and overall what kind
of role do you want this movie to have
for an audience member in 2018
today well the best thing would be if
people want to maybe to be entertained
because it does have all those bells and
whistles of a suspense thriller but that
you know underneath that I think is an
example of how of the kind of national
trauma and
double trauma that's produced by people
who are convinced to do terrible things
by a demagogue who utilizes race hatred
and that these things aren't as a way
they're in the past or distant from us
but it's happening all the time
you